[Music]
Clint Eastwood appeared today on Good
Morning America to promote his new movie
this is the first time I think he's
given an extended on-camera interview
yeah
since his speech at Republican National
Convention and I watched him this
morning on Good Morning America and it
was I gotta say it was classic Clint now
to Clint Eastwood he's starring in his
first movie in four years and he sat
down with ABC to talk all about it
there's something about the aging
process that makes you give a crap less
and same delight
[Applause]
I don't want to do that first place I'm
not very good at that
my wife takes care of us that stuff
[Applause]